j'étais pas la radio cet après midi j'ai
un truc inavouables à vous dire et vous
avez tous avoir un truc inavouables nous
raconter ici je vous le dis moi je sais
mais je vous jure que c'est vrai j'ai
pleuré devant le le grand frère cet
après midi j'étais pas bien j'ai vu le
grand frère j'ai vu c'est ma famille qui
se retrouvaient c'était pas bien j'en ai
chialé les gars on s'attendait tous à
lui seul
tout ça est ce que vous avez quelque
chose d'inavouable à dire aux
téléspectateurs ce soir là tout de suite
maintenant oui bah on veut on repasse à
saluer
oui en fait quand j'étais petit mais ça
s'est passé plutôt à mes parents je suis
partie au commissaire hier en fait parce
que j'étais dans un centre commercial
est en fête avec un copain on m'avait
volé et c'était pas bien et je veux pas
tu dois je vous avais dit à mes parents
que c'était moi qui avait volé donc
c'est tout tout est retombé sur mon pote
il s'est pris des gifs par tout le monde
est en fait j'avais volé un truc
complètement ridicule et je tiens à le
dire ce soir j'ai quoi l'oranje non pire
en fait j'étais fan de poisson rouge et
j'ai volé des hameçons pour pêcher non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa révolte donc c'était la dernière fois
vous aviez volé ces derniers d'accord
batterie kaboul et avec deux véritables
avouables
le problème c'est que j'avais pas 13 ans
c'est l'année dernière deux mois j'ai
volé des hameçons est-ce que c'est à
dire de il ya trois mois j'étais tout
seul donc personne c'est ouais j'étais à
montmartre et j'ai fait un resto basket
mais tout seul c'est à dire en baston
talons on va dire voilà 35 ans c'est
quoi le 20 km l'addition je me suis dit
je me fais un cap ou pas moi même et je
me suis dit est ce que je suis capable
d'en sortir par la porte et demain
clonés et de pas payer un mois la jeune
il était ce sens
et je pense à tous les restaurateurs qui
font leur métier est une épreuve avec la
tva et dalla riva le paye pas c'est
moche statham dans sa solitude se disent
moi j'ai été serveur et quand on est
serveur comme quelqu'un se barrer sans
payer ses serveurs qui doit payer
exactement réfère non c'est à vous que
je vais donner l'oseille calade aurait
dû donner la même histoire
bordeaux quelque chose d'inavouable à
part votre personne alors moi quelques
années quand tu étais sorti le week end
quand on sortait que les copains on se
mettait vraiment ares allez y avait une
bande de décodage et mathieu il ya des
gens courageux mais où wilfrid walter wb
beaucoup et trop mais ça m'est déjà
arrivé maintenant on habitait au premier
étage ça m'est arrivé de rester dans
l'escalier toute la nuit par monter le
premier wallon la lie
alors quand j'aurai plus ils ont besoin
c'est un soir je rentre et je vois bien
un peu comme vous que je me couche
et ça tourne ça tourne ça tourne ça
tourne et là vous avez un appétit non là
je vomis tout nouveau meeting surtout
dans le temps dans l'es10 chez moi elle
était tellement mal que je suis resté
dedans me suis rendormi de nos morts
dans le monde jusqu'au lendemain
le lendemain tu très bien changer les
draps le matelas imbibé ya pas d'alès
donc c'est dégueulasse pendant un mois
dans ta chambre
ah ouais donc il fallait changer de lit
mais j'avais pas d'argent tiens
d'ailleurs sur la [ __ ] mon coup de
gueule le prix des leaders mais bosser
c'est bon c'est bon ok merci aux parents
il ya quand même quelqu'un juste deux
minutes mener la bonne et la badea
il ya quand même quelques uns aussi qu'
apparemment il ya vovk il ya fauves qui
a vomi sur la tête sous
[Musique]
si on y arrive quelque chose
d'inavouable c'est tellement un fonds
bout j'ai dit ouais un jour je suis
rentré sans quelqu'un sans me suis
dépêché quelqu'un alors ça va hier on
vous dira alors et c'est qu'on dise oh
yeah quoi dans les loges si vous avez
fait quand il n'aura s'échanger j'ai
regarder ses fesses
[Applaudissements]
non la doit qu'à lui met un petit à la
merco sont pas du tout la vraie question
que mon questionnement nous a regardé
derrière
voyez que ça la vraie question que tout
le monde se pose comment sont ses fesses
très joli
[Applaudissements]
pas mal alors là on n'est pas d'accord
y'a pas d'exploit elle les montre à tout
le monde
[Rires]
qu'est ce que tu as quelque chose d'une
avoir bouclé sauf ayala c'est
dégueulasse c'est quoi ben voilà c'est
dur a avoué j'ai un plaisir coupable en
faites pas vous ronger les ongles des
pieds
non sans blague alors je le fais on a
systématiquement je vous rassure j'adore
me tue ruiné et lui je vous jure que
c'est vrai la dernière fois il a sorti
de boule de zidane il était au bowling
suisse prend pas de boules est fait
comme ça il a sorti la boîte
allez y en a deux à faire cela sur le
continent et d'ailleurs et ya là un
regard gaga au canada c'est de mes gars
mais je vais prêter discrètement non
mais c'est vrai quoi m est toujours le
voyage et un mouchoir non non j'ai un
mouchoir et tout ce dont j'ai
l'impression d'être éviterait de jeu
vite fait de vous serrer la main alors
rien à lui d'ailleurs il est très propre
heureusement parce que celui-ci devait
sortir missy sortait les crocs de zen
lui c'est la comète de halley des gones
était petit et ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il ya tout le système solaire dans son
élan vers des sites chinois c'est pas
une radio ça on aura on aura votre truc
qui d'avoir un instant je voulais je
vous laisse pour la fin et doha votre
votre truc inavoués a bien quand même
acquéreur qui vient de tomber
un cadreur vient de tomber alors oui
bonsoir c'est une anecdote vrai lors
d'un entretien d'embauché j'avais
extrêmement extrêmement envie de faire
pipi et je me suis uriné dessus juste
dans l'entretien au rouge avait des
collants ça faisait des bulles de pie
pistolets arriver j'espère palais de
pupi on dirait une chanson de mylène
farmer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
est ce qui est génial c'est que pendant
l'entretien d'embauché
le patron j'étais jeune j'avais 20 ans
me disais c'est pas possible je suis
vraiment navré jeune fille parce qu'il
ya une odeur dans mon bureau vraiment je
suis désolé parce que le ménage n'a pas
été fait le mec a ouvert les fenêtres
c'est juste moi qui a été vraiment et
tout un pipi au parec aussi dans ce même
bureau hiraga caveau me vila vous voulez
nous avouer ce soir est beau aussi à
hashtag quelque chose d'inavouable qq
chose d'inavouable bien sûr et vous me
dites comme ça où les mettra sur les
taux sur les missions pour soir sur ça
alors avant de la raconter je dois dire
que je m'excuse auprès d'un monsieur
très respectable parce que j'ai vraiment
vous dirai après donc en fait c'était au
printemps d'anecdotes et au printemps
chez moi ça cool ça coule de partout
parce que tu es au magasin printemps non
au printemps la saison c'est la période
des allergies donc ça roule ça ouais
ouais mon mais oui quand ça cool je vous
explique adam la fois qu'il a coulé du
nez ils ont cru cas d'un dégât des eaux
les grands
[Musique]
jour là ce jour là c'était toi là non on
appelait alors et un truc un concept à
sauter laventure fait sonné au rafting
c'est génial pour ceux qui aiment
l'aventuré pour ceux qui aiment la folie
voilà un petit sac à dos vous allez dans
son nez au rap qui bonne heure c'est
l'école a coulé nez bouché les oreilles
aussi parce que le système est comme ça
coule de partout rien du tout j'étais en
loge j'étais en loge et c'était ma
première saison ici
oui voilà et donc ça coulait tellement
que j'avais honte de sortir pour trouver
un mouchoir ou et je vois ce moment là
dans une veste partant pour le pressing
un bon mouchoirs sans doute en soie
blanche dépassant non pour ne pas sortir
loin je pense bouchoir et j'en mets
partout sinon le mouchoir moment je me
soulage dans le mouchoir et ben dispo je
repose le mouchoir dans la veste et à ce
moment là je vois gérard louvin qui
revient du maquillage
[Rires]
non
bling c'est que ce n'est pas du tout une
veste pour le pressing c'était la veste
et le bon mouchoirs en saura de gérard
louvin dans six pays conserve
religieusement d'or dont qui met sa
veste et épicentre du maquillage il
avait un peu chaud il prend son mouchoir
ils s'arrangent le front nord j'adore
bravo
c'est tout à votre honneur d'avouer et
je vous lis non mais je vous le dis
bravo
il va venir à semaine prochaine durant
il dit nous disant qu'il en jean luc
lemoine n'a pas présenté les gens sans
foi tient pas sa nature et histoire
alors oui non moyen 2 je suis comme vous
j'ai pleuré devant pascal le grand frère
mais était devant moi il m'a tapée donc
c'était et danser c'est un truc honteux
mais j'étais tout petit jeu si je veux
demander pardon à ma famille en fait on
était à l'hôtel avec ma famille l époque
qui avait pas de télé dans tout dans
toutes les chambres
il y avait des salons de thé de télé non
dans les hôtels et donc on descend avec
ma famille après manger pour aller au
salon de télé et on est rentré et tous
ont été concentrés je suis rentré j'ai
pété gptd tout le monde s'est retourné
la famille était très gêné en début de
partie leur touche tous alors je vais
vous dire un jean-luc c'est tout à votre
honneur vous aussi d'avouer parce que
comme on dit fait avouée à moitié
pardonnée bravo là
aujourd'hui c'est tout à votre honneur
vraiment bravo au long du quai je suis
fier d'eux oui je sens que ça mau nord
vraiment bravo
[Musique]
oh